the woman in the middle of the Chloe
cheating scandal Kylie's best friend
Jordan woods takes a seat and brings her
truth to Jada Pinkett Smith's red table
did you sleep with Tristan never God
never a thought another consideration
never happened and never will I I'm no
homewrecker especially someone that I
love and someone who has a beautiful
daughter and there it is
Jordans complete denial that she got
intimate with Chloe's ex Tristan
Thompson the alleged affair was rumored
to have taken place nearly two weeks ago
during an after-party at his home so
this is where the story gets chicken I
was but I was not beyond the point of
recollection on the way out he did kiss
me but no tongue kiss no making out did
you say anything to him like I was just
like I need to go I was like hmm let me
just pretend like that didn't happen and
Jordan says that it's exactly what she
did hours later when she spoke to Kylie
and Khloe on the phone I was honest
about being there but I wasn't honest
about the actions that had taken place
do you feel as though you are the reason
why ersten and Chloe are not together I
know I'm not the reason
Chloe shot Jordans version of events
down the moment that exchange streamed
live Khloe tweeted quote if you're going
to try and save yourself by going public
instead of calling me privately to
apologize first at least be honest about
your story by the way you are the reason
my family broke up I did as much
apologizing as I could do over the phone
over text
[Music]